[Music]
goddamn your hands are cold Jesus do the
armpit thing no this week we've got a
forgiving businessmen a stupid parent
and force compliments taken away Tiffany
okay you have to add that for our first
story there was this Vietnamese
businessman - done with the story as it
is good movies I already know what's
going on tell me what happened nothing I
don't know go ahead I'm kidding I just
said get something dirty or cheap tactic
said that huh no next Chinese bro oh
they're all doubly degenerate he was a
generous I don't think VIN Ameen
stereotype is shady I've never heard
that let me hear that from Koreans and
Chinese excuse me yeah I hear that a lot
that Koreans you shouldn't work with
them cuz they're this is old-school
thinking no it's it's current thinking
Koreans like you face I think really
Shady
I thought the stereotype was they just
get mad at you out of nowhere
maybe amongst Asians but outside of the
Asian Circle really like that even
Mexicans no specifically that's true
Mexicans no Asians Allah because they
work together alive so you think I like
the Mexican job agencies they're like
looking up the back history full [ __ ]
Korean or like Chinese business now
let's go with the chinos yeah Korean
boyfriend innocent as my dad found out
that he was Korean my dad's like I
[ __ ] hate him he's gonna be Shady
gonna turn out to be true while we're
not together but it wasn't raining see
listen just think you were sneaky that's
kind of shady yeah okay then he was
shady sneaky Korean boyfriend Hawkinson
my my family my aunt was dating a Korean
dude that looked like mr. Miyagi my dad
would call and then still like he was
like he was well up and he would always
help my aunt and stuff and so we always
thought of Koreans as being really
generous nice they are generous my dad
just did a lot of business with
different ethnic people and Koreans is
home away he hated every culture has a
dark side yeah for sure for sure every
single one could the stereotypes with
Korean people is that they are they kind
of like hate on a lot of other Asians
but they hate on the Asians that they
have the same quality so like they're
like all Chinese people are so dirty
they're poor business tactics but the
difference is Chinese people are upfront
with it they actually think it's okay
they just don't know but with Korean
people that's where that two-faced thing
comes in because they're all smiles at
first but in the back they're doing like
shady shitty accent they're here that's
the stereotype you know I mean I'm not
like that
you're rare so his Bentley was hit by a
concrete mixer she owns a [ __ ]
Bentley is it in Vietnam Vietnam so let
me tell you a little bit of story about
luxury tax in a Vietnam so a Bentley is
already expensive here right imagine
paying double of what you're paying for
Bentley here because that's how much
luxury cars and taxes like all that [ __ ]
is like he's double ballin you're yeah
you're paying like outrageous amounts of
money for luxury car they're like even a
BMW or Mercedes for businessmen yeah I
think the stereotype is it doesn't exist
I thought is they like to pay $10 for a
coffee so they could look at girls in
bikinis
they're smart or their level of business
is like I don't know like boba shop or
so2 or coffee shop restaurant yeah so
stereotype your nails nails yeah why da
hell what the hell but then like I don't
think there's a stereotype of like
business no you know like industry and
like I'm not sure what exactly he does
but here the businessman he does own a
Bentley and his Bentley was hit by a
concrete mixer and so when the truck
driver of that concrete mixer discovered
that he accidentally hit the car he was
just like freaking out he's like oh my
god I don't know what to do I barely
have any money to get by my parents are
sick so you gotta cut your arms off
southern uh fan which is the driver the
businessman he immediately he just told
him like don't worry man we are best
friend no no before you found out about
like his was right before that whoa he
was telling him that he he should pay
the dolt
the driver cut this is why I stumble on
my words guys you guys always ask me you
choose funny words you're like oh my god
you tell me your walls all down my words
and then I forget what I'm saying and
then hey I got your back I agree
forget about your vows TIFF let's go
okay so then he asked them to pay 300
million Vietnamese dong which is about
13,000 $200 to give a pickle to to pay
for it the the damage of his car and so
that's when you just go really he can't
because he's broke and then that's when
he was just like you know what forget
about it don't worry about I don't pay
me [ __ ] this is Pam the business man
that's a nice teeth hey he's a
good-looking dude and he's rich Wow Wow
nice and straight okay
what happen is Bentley he's like come on
man have any of you been inside a
Bentley before never have I don't know
what it's like I wanted it what's the
base price on a Bentley and there's like
$200,000 I think it's the poor man's
rolls-royce I'm not sure if that's
actually true really yeah cuz there's
some cars over a half a million someone
like a million dollars what's inside
Internet and like I just know like those
cars aren't meant for you to drive it is
for you to be driven in yeah they start
at 180,000 that's why that's why that
Continental GT 2 which is their coupe
was like their entry-level coupe I
forgot what show I was watching but it
was like a rapper came in and he bought
it for like oh she was a she she bought
it for like two hundred and fifty
thousand cash like BAM I won't say cash
walked out with that [ __ ] I felt like
Bentley's lost their luxury quality like
the way Maserati did is cuz rappers keep
buying it mmm whatever rappers touch
something just shitty so Cristal did the
right thing by like not wanting to be
affiliated with rappers yeah they were
just saying like we have no affiliation
with them like like we don't have any
sort of partnership and then a lot of
the rapper starting a pissed and then I
know one of them specifically jay-z was
like [ __ ] y'all then I'm never gonna
promote their song okay you already put
it in songs those already nodded so it's
already done and huh
y'all don't want me to drink a drink so
what was the news reporting this like
and what a nice guy man yeah they're
just like man what a man with a generous
heart I mean if I had millions and a
freaking poor trucker hit my car and he
was like down and out I don't think I'd
do it either I think it's [ __ ] up cuz
it's if how much is it gonna cost to fix
that thing like $20,000 or something
thirteen thousand thirteen thousand
thirteen thousand to him is like 20
bucks to us that's true when my Jeep
when I first got it within the first
week or two some dude hit the back of it
everyone always hit your car and it was
your people that did it and I said that
person probably doesn't have a shirt
and I let him go he's not even a citizen
probably want to go went to put in gas
and went into the station to get some
snacks came out it's went boom was it
what the [ __ ] made eye contact the guy
looked at Minnie went make his life
anyway on the flip
now you should have [ __ ] that guy over
wait wait on the flip the universe does
bones itself out because I don't know
what Bart did that I guess he thought he
had his foot on the brake but he did it
the car rolled tap the car in front of
them the the guy in front of them like
looked in his rear Vermeer him and the
guy I made eye contact and the guy
didn't say anything cuz he probably
didn't have insurance so you see it was
good it was still in that person's favor
yeah insurance but then he got deported
I mean who knows he could have chart he
can you could have given him cash he
would've been like his you know and not
involved insurance I just feel like
we're showing some where's your license
Aeneid oh you must be English story that
would have been the exact story I like
that story a lot where surance no listen
I don't speak English wait for our next
story
there was this mom this stupid mom from
Wisconsin stupid as mom she allowed her
nine-year-old son to write on the roof
of her minivan which Walter in order to
hold down a plastic pool I thought it
was just like in a circle in a park
around I might do that
amber 28 years old oh that's the mom
yeah this is the mom she like she's
fresh out of high school she has really
soft hair think about right now this
woman nearly murdered her child yeah I
mean look at her hair
you [ __ ] dudes yeah so so you could
tell if someone's a murderer with their
hair by their hair what you could tell
if someone's a murder by their hair no
it was just an observation had no
connection to the story at all
whatsoever
cuz I could always tell by the eyebrows
I wasn't even thinking about the hair I
thought her skin look really soft yes
I just wanted to come up and just go do
this and [ __ ] backhand the side of
her face she doesn't look like a
murderer
she didn't murder anyone she's just
stupid she's just dumb she wasn't trying
to hurt her kid the question is that the
kid requested pretty sure kids want some
fun [ __ ] they're something but she let
her kid do it because when she was a kid
her parents let her do it right on top
of yeah like right on top of the car
like trying to hold down low key though
if I was at nine year old I'd be [ __ ]
down and if no one else is looking every
kid was I'd be like in the parking lot
I'd be like all right I do you watch
that's back in our day well mothers be
able to ride on the back of pickup
trucks yeah and then my dad had a truck
at a camper and I always wanted to ride
in the back with the dog it's fun yeah I
volunteer to you guys ever like surf do
like this yeah I would try to stand up
I'll try to do all kinds of things and
me and my dad just never write it in the
trunk the trunk in high school when you
pack like eight kids in a car with me
guarantee we never got to sit in the
front I always had to write a [ __ ] way
with my parents with my parents or with
my friends oh yeah with my friends never
with my parents she let me in the trunk
but it was only for one block she's like
she was like I will not drive further
than one but that's where Isaac gets it
from because I think always want
surprise - it's fun as a kid for sure
but then the trunk and the roof are
completely different like the roof is
just [ __ ] I the roof is just dumb
like you can simply just get blown off
the car and then you're done with the
pool - the plastic pool like once it
catches that wind I should [ __ ] gone
yeah it's this point strapped down earth
know so this is the reason why she put a
kid in that casita
she's like no other way to strap down
the pool so she needed the kids wait yes
that's why she put how big is this kid
he's like 200 pounds nine no I don't
know how many well I was about a hundred
I was nine so different kids way
different amount that's just gonna be
like a sliding plate on top of a car
just lead waiting ahead onto the freeway
someone saw her driving down the street
and they called 9-1-1 and that's why i'm
the 9-1-1 or the cops pulled her over so
the kid didn't slide off no but now
she's facing up to ten years in prison
oh no no that's not enough to take the
kid away from this mom that's kind of
stupid I think that one what they should
have super glued the kids hands to the
roof rails exactly you know it just
sounds like that whole area it's just
filled with a bunch of dumb people
Wisconsin of course just that area not
always constitution of that area it's in
Wisconsin yes I don't know anybody from
this constant no I don't think that's
right I think they should just educate
her and you know I see check out on the
kid to see if you know if they have a
loving relationship if he's well fed how
the house is like and everything is cool
it just turns out she's a [ __ ] then
it's different for a dot add that
question to the DMV test if you need
straps and you put your kid on and then
so now you can educate like the whole
state at once every single thing that's
extremely stupid just put it into the
DMV test so that everyone is all
notified at the same time I think the
real thing is was she going 15 miles per
hour because then it's saying hey true
that's what she goes she's going like
three miles an hour
yeah they don't mention how fast she
just says that it was twenty or thirty
seconds is what she says there the cops
got there that fast no no that the kid
or that the kid was only up there for
twenty or thirty and then she brought
him down again
it was too dangerous cuz I want to see
the full the full breadth of the story
and I just I don't know how do people
got to get involved if the whole family
dies let them be no baby bad night story
or a last story here uh there was this
Maui judge that ordered a man to write
144 nice things about his ex-girlfriend
that's impossible I just take jail time
dude a judge in Maui yeah
can you write a hundred and forty-four
nice things about your girlfriend
girlfriend or ex Mina has an ex
girlfriend even through married Oh 100
words hard did they get into a fight and
it was like the law had to get involved
the ex-girlfriend ex-girlfriend had a
protection order and he kept harassing
her and would send her nasty text
messages and calls and so apparently it
was it was a hundred and forty-four
nasty texts and calls and so the judge
said for every nasty thing you said you
have to say a nice thing and you can't
repeat the word how come you don't cook
pancakes for me anymore
say just to put it in my perspective how
hard that is Bart say 20 nice things
about geo right now off the bat just on
five five Oviatt orange yesterday on JK
party he was emailed it yeah
20 25 no 500 fog is easy but you already
use those so you can't use them again
that's how you another five you're very
intelligent you are very loving and
nurturing and you have beautiful eyes
think you said that one yesterday I know
I did it all right
yeah you're very disciplined oh thank
you oh we should do ones that are real
though so let's try again you make
chilaquiles yeah I heard you touch of
the killers into our bar oh [ __ ] that's
Mexican ice [ __ ] yeah there's more nice
things well thank you well that works
you see you go woo same area and you
give good [ __ ]
Muriel Muriel what nice things are just
things nice things nice things she has
skin she has fingernails she has eyes
she can walk and she can talk you guys
are lovers [ __ ] quick-witted so hard
you know Asian compliments art if
someone tells you you're not stupid you
alive I don't kick you out of the house
you're not poor BAM compliments
compliments why couple notes about KC
right now off the bat oh he's smart he's
well-spoken he's a great chef he's very
loving very romantic and that was quick
what the [ __ ] you guys are loving [ __ ]
that's [ __ ] married she had bowels
in her head still you know it's like if
we do a replace she was doing this he's
very good I like that one of my heart is
[ __ ] but so this guy here his name is
Darren thirty years old
and so he was order or he was sentenced
he was sentenced to write these 144
complements as well as two years of
probation a $2,400 fine and 200 hours of
community service it sounds like a just
in 54 what is it what would that be
considered harassment like harassment
sexual - why he's also a [ __ ] at the
she put a restraining order on him right
yeah so you file any natural sure I
never expect that kind of stuff out all
right I don't think I could ever like
somebody enough to do that [ __ ] to watch
it like you break up and then you harass
them no no 30 years old yeah exactly
you're not a loser I'm moving on to the
next chapter in my life yeah
it's too much work to harass somebody
dude Oh what if you really love that
person and then they dumped you
you still wouldn't know I would just cry
to myself and then yeah if you love
someone why would you abuse them
verbally like you do that because you
hate them yeah you know I'm saying I
would just like look at them at a
distance and Washington date their new
person and then [ __ ] them cry
you know like was it that the most
interesting you've ever heard and your
whole entire life I don't even know what
you guys just talked about but anyways
please subscribe for more random videos
more funny content and more hahaha
poopoo in your pants stuff go ahead
subscribe and for more videos right now